Your words aren't having the impact that
you want because you're writing the way
that you speak and not the way that
readers read. The way that you speak is
full of verbal ticks that make your
ideas sound dull. It's because when we
speak, our mouth often moves faster than
we can think. So, we use these fillers
to maintain fluency while searching for
the next word. Great for speaking,
terrible for writing. That's because
readers process information differently.
They don't want you to write like you
speak. If they did, they wouldn't be
readers. They'd be listeners. So readers
want your writing to be like computer
code. Simple, elegant, and efficient.
Give them bloated, inarticulate writing,
and they'll struggle to understand your
ideas, no matter how valuable your ideas
are. So, in this video, I'm going to
show you what I've learned in 10 years
of teaching writing from the reader's
perspective. This semester, I used these
principles to help one client get into
MIT on a full ride PhD and another to
obtain grant funding for a startup that
they spun out of their own research. And
to be clear, these clients are brilliant
on their own, but like many experts, you
could have all the talent in the world
and it won't make a lick of difference
if you don't know how to write about it.
So, let me give you an example. If I
write, in my personal opinion, it is
necessary that we should not ignore the
opportunity to think over each and every
suggestion offered. That's clear. It's
not difficult to understand the intended
meaning, and there aren't any mistakes
in the grammar, but it sounds dull and
more importantly, it makes the writer
sound inarticulate for three reasons.
First, opinion is always personal. So,
we don't need in my personal opinion.
And since this statement is an opinion,
we don't even need to say in my opinion.
Second, think over and not ignore both
mean the same thing, which is consider.
We can just delete that. And each and
every is redundant. We can probably just
go with every. And by definition,
suggestions are offered. So we don't
need to say suggestion offered. So when
we clean it up, we could express exactly
the same message with a sentence like
this. We should consider every
suggestion. Now, why does that work
better? I mean, this sentence is
shorter, yes, but the point is not
simply to shorten sentences. Sentence
length doesn't actually matter if you
know how to shape your sentences
properly, but that's another lesson. The
reason that this second sentence is
better is compression. It cuts
redundancy and bloat, which puts less
cognitive load on your reader and
articulates your ideas clearly. So, how
do you make sure that your writing is
compact and efficient? Well, there are
five things that you can do to sharpen
your ideas. Three of them are about
pruning and two of them involve adding
back in. So, if you want your ideas to
land not only with clarity but with
force, implement these five writing
techniques to start. Why do so many
experts sound vague and uncertain in
their writing? Well, I think it's
because they've been following one of
the worst pieces of writing advice out
there, which is write the way that you
speak. This really misleads writers. It
forces them to fill up their writing
with these verbal ticks. And the problem
is that when we're speaking, our brain
can't keep up with our mouth. So, we use
a lot of filler words, which is, of
course, words like um and a, but also a
set of more common words that you're
probably using in your writing without
even realizing it. And they're really
watering down your message. So, if you
learn to identify and eliminate these
words, you're going to become more
precise and you'll be able to establish
yourself as an authority in the mind of
your reader. These words are like throat
clearing before you speak. They're
nervous habits that dilute your message
before you even begin. So for example,
consider the following sentence. Student
engagement actually depends on certain
elements that basically involve
curiosity more than any particular
curriculum. So here we've got a few
filler words like actually, certain,
basically that sound perfectly natural
when we're speaking, but in the mind of
your reader, they turn your message into
something that's bloated, flabby, and
imprecise. So when you remove these
filler words, you get something much
leaner. Student engagement depends on I
can just remove this whole thing.
Curiosity more than any particular
curriculum more than curriculum. That's
just an example. But here are some other
filler words that belong in spoken
language but not your writing. actually,
basically, certain, various,
particularly, really, virtually,
individual, generally, given,
practically. These words, of course,
they have their own purpose. Every word
has a purpose, but in general, they are
the culprits of bloated writing and they
add virtually no meaning to your text.
They're like verbal static. So, get them
out. The idea here is that in your
writing, you want to be ruthless in
trying to pare down your message. The
point is not just to have short
sentences. It's to cut the fat and make
your writing as lean as possible so that
you can achieve clarity through
minimalism. By the way, if you want to
learn to write well, then you are going
to love my free newsletter, Writer
Science. Link is down below the like
button. Speaking of writing that seems
vague and bloated and unclear and
imprecise, there's another category of
words that writers use without really
thinking about it. They think it makes
them sound more authoritative and
complete, knowledgeable and
authoritative, when in fact it just
makes them sound redundant and
repetitive. This habit dates back
centuries, and back then it had a
purpose, but today it just sounds like
overkill. These are called dublets.
Various and multiple. Think and believe.
Fully and completely, true and accurate,
each and every. First and foremost, any
and all, basic and fundamental. These
doubled words originated when English
writers would pair French or Latin words
together with Anglo-Saxon words. It was
a way of showing that they were learned.
For example, aid and a bet. Well, aid
comes from French, while a bet comes
from old French. Null and void. Well,
null is Latin and void is French. Peace
and quiet. Peace is French and quiet is
Latin. During the Norman conquest and
the centuries that followed, using these
pairs demonstrated to your reader that
you knew multiple languages, so you
established yourself as an authority.
But these phrases still hang around in
our lexicon today. But modern readers
don't have any use for them. So whenever
you find yourself using one of these
dublets, just choose the strongest one
and move on. The thing that's making
your ideas to sound imprecise and dull
is actually the hardest one to catch.
Mastering this is what separates
competent writers from exceptional ones.
So you know whenever you read a phrase
like I saw it with my own eyes, well
it's a common enough expression, but
when you really start to think about it,
you've got to say, well, of course you
saw it with your own eyes. I mean, what
else are you going to see it with? This
is a particular kind of redundancy and
catching turns of phrase like this.
Well, that's what readers use to judge
between writers who are paying attention
and those who just don't know what
they're doing. So, it really comes down
to three types of redundancy. Modifiers,
categories, and general implications.
These are words that are implied by
other words. So, let's start with
modifiers. These are the words that
contain their modifier within them. So
for example, look at this sentence. Do
not attempt to anticipate upcoming
trends that will totally transform
education because previous experience
shows that it is the ultimate result of
small shifts that suddenly astonishes us
more. This sentence is filled with words
that you just don't need because other
words in the sentence already carry that
meaning. The word anticipate already
implies upcoming. So you don't need to
say upcoming trends. The word transform
already contains the meaning of the word
totally. So we don't need that. You
don't partially transform. It's a
transient. You're transing your form.
Experience always happens in the past.
So we don't need to say previous
experience. And results always happen at
the end. So we don't need to say
ultimate result. And astonishment always
happens all of a sudden. I mean you
can't really be gradually astonished by
anything. So we don't need to say
suddenly. Cut these redundant modifiers
and you're left with something much more
precise. Do not attempt to anticipate
trends that will transform education
because experience shows that it is the
result of small shifts that astonishes
us more. So what are some examples of
words that you can cut from your own
writing? Well, you kind of have to
develop your own ear for this, but there
are some common culprits like core
essentials, basic fundamentals, future
plans, free gift, consensus of opinion
in actual reality. You get the idea?
Well, the next type of word that's
unnecessary because it is implied by
other words is categories. So, here's a
quick example. During that phase of
development, the interface design became
intuitive in nature and responsive in
function. Every word in this sentence
implies its category. So phase is a unit
of development. Interface is an aspect
of design and responsive is obviously
referring to function. Remove those and
you get something more like this. During
that phase, the interface became
intuitive and responsive. Other common
culprits in redundant categories are
phrases like large in size, unusual in
nature, round in shape, and at an early
time. These are redundancies you're just
going to have to watch out for. There's
no solid rule or principle except to say
that you don't usually need to specify
the category that something belongs to.
It's already implied by the word itself.
Now, sometimes when you're fixing this
kind of mistake, you're going to need to
convert adjectives into adverbs. So, for
example, in the sentence, the paragraphs
must be organized in a logical manner.
Well, logical and manner are the same
words, but you can't just delete manner.
So, you need to turn it into an adverb.
They they must be organized logically.
All right. This last type of word that
you want to delete are general
implications. And honestly, these are
the hardest ones to catch because the
redundancy spreads across multiple
words. You really just need to be a
ruthless editor trying to delete as much
as possible. So, for example, look at
this sentence. Imagine someone
attempting to learn the conventions for
writing the art of poetry. So, this
sentence is not imprecise because of
modifiers or categories. Instead, the
redundancy is spread across multiple
words and phrases. So for example, the
verb learn already implies the idea of
trying to do something. So it's
redundant to say attempting to learn.
And the same thing goes for conventions.
It implies writing in the genre. If
you're learning about the genre of
poetry, then by definition, you are
learning conventions. Similarly, poetry
is an art. So we don't need to say the
art of poetry. And when you come to a
sentence like this with the intention of
removing as much as possible, you can
hack away a lot of this deadwood and
you'll be left with something a lot more
crisp, like imagine learning the
conventions of poetry. All right, so
those last three points showed you all
the places where you could cut extra
words, but these next two are about what
you can add back in. Because even after
cutting all that redundancy, many
writers still use five words when they
could just use one. So, this is your
opportunity to flex your vocabulary
muscle and use the thesaurus that's been
gathering dust because we are going to
be finding what the French call lies,
the exact right word. Take a sentence
like this. As you thoroughly review what
you have written to enhance clarity and
identify problems of organization and
flow, the thing to do before anything
else is to see whether you could use
concrete illustrations instead of the
same concepts presented in less concrete
terms. Now, in this passage, there
aren't exactly words that you could cut,
but we can still make this passage a lot
more efficient. And the difference here
is a little bit like taking a
cross-country road trip versus taking a
direct flight. We can't just make the
road trip more efficient. We need to
change the vehicle that we're taking,
which means finding more precise words.
And this is one of the great things
about having a wide vocabulary. Many
people will abuse their vocabulary and
just use obscure words just because. Use
a $50 word where a $5 word will do. But
when you have a wider vocabulary or you
know how to use a thesaurus, then you
can compress your ideas and articulate
them more efficiently. I mean, take this
part. As you thoroughly review what you
have written to enhance clarity and
identify problems of organization and
flow, well, that's a bit of a mouthful.
What if we just turn what if we just use
the verb revise?
as you revise that's one word and it
captures the same meaning now what about
this revise what you have written well
normally I don't like to use
nominalizations which is where we take a
clause or an action and we represent it
as a noun but since the verb revise is a
transitive verb it needs a it needs an
object it needs something to receive the
revising so it wants a direct object to
receive that action And I find it a
little bit awkward to use a clause as
the object of an action verb. So we can
take this we can take this clause and
just capture it with a noun like your
writing. Now what about the thing to do
before anything else? Well, we could
just capture that with a word like
first. And then how about this
structure? Use X instead of Y. Well, we
could just use the verb replace.
That'll save us some room. Replace
concrete illustrations with the same
concepts. And then how that concrete
illustrations? Well, there's a word for
that. That would be examples. And the
same concepts presented in less concrete
terms. Well, how about
abractions?
But now the verb replace has a slightly
different structure. So, we need to
switch these two things. So, we're going
to put replace examples with
abstractions. And that leaves us with a
sentence like, "As you revise your
writing, first replace abstractions with
examples." This is one of the things
that comes from spoken language. We use
these really clumsy phrases. The reason
for instead of why, despite the fact
that, instead of even though or
although, in the event that instead of
if. in a situation where instead of when
concerning the matter of instead of
about. Now, once again, there's no
formula for this. We just need
vocabulary and alertness and the desire
to pair down our writing. But one way
that you can watch out for this is to
look when you're editing. Just look
through the words to the ideas. If
you're using many words to express only
a few ideas, there's probably some
replacements that you could use to
articulate the idea more precisely. The
way to sound more articulate in your
writing doesn't really have to do with
using fewer words, although that is a
happy byproduct. Yes, writers who ignore
this principle wind up using more words
than is necessary. But the reason that
writing this way makes you sound
inarticulate is because it forces your
readers to do some mental arithmetic
before they can understand your point.
That's what happens when you don't write
in the affirmative. Or more directly,
that's what happens when you write in
the negative. Negatives force your
reader to take an extra step. First,
they need to process your sentence and
second they need to reverse it. And
depending on the way you write it, this
reversal can happen three, four, five
times per sentence. Affirmatives are a
lot more direct and they make your
writing sound so much more clear. So,
for example, in the sentence, do not
write in the negative, well, you could
switch that to write in the positive.
That's simple enough, but watch what
happens when negatives get compounded
with other words that secretly carry
negative connotations. But first, here
are some simple translations. Not
different, similar. Not the same,
different. Not allow, prevent. Not
notice, overlook. Not many, few. Not
often, rarely. Not include, omit. So,
that's simple enough. But the real
danger comes when you compound your
negatives, as in this sentence, which
says, except when you have failed to
submit applications without
documentation, benefits will not be
denied. How many times do you need to
reverse this sentence in your mind? We
have accept, failed, without, and not be
denied. Here's what this sentence
actually means. To receive
benefits, submit
your documents.
It's so much more clear when we write it
in the positive. But the worst case is
when negatives combine with passive
sentences and nominalizations. As we see
in this sentence, which says, "There
should be no submission of payments
without notification of this office
unless the payment does not exceed
$100." What? How do we begin fixing this
sentence? Well, the first thing that we
need to do is to get the action out of
these nouns and into verbs. So,
submission becomes submit and
notification becomes notify. So that
would be do not submit
payments and then it would be uh if you
do not notify do not notify
this
office and then there's another clause
which is like the payment does not
exceed
$100. So let's get exceeded out of there
and we'll say
unless
you
pay
you are paying
less
than 100. All right. So we've got three
clauses there. But we could still make
this more clear by switching it into the
positive because we have not not and
less than. So all these negatives are
not not less. So let's switch it and say
if you are paying more than $100, notify
this office. And at that point, we don't
even need this clause at all. And so the
principle here is to watch out for words
that are implicitly negative. words like
preclude, prevent, lack, fail, doubt,
reject, avoid, deny, refuse, exclude,
contradict, prohibit, bar, without,
against, unless, and accept. When these
words combine with explicit negatives,
which are not and no, and words like
that, comprehension collapses. But there
is one exception to this principle. You
want to keep negatives when you actually
want to emphasize what not to do.
Sometimes the warning is the point, but
otherwise write in the positive.
Compression in writing is only the
start. Once you've cut the deadwood, you
need to spruce things up a little bit.
So, watch this video next because it
breaks down 31 writing tools from some
of the greatest writers of all time.
Byite-siz tips that you can use right
away. So, be sure to go check it out.